well the lame duck he tried to show some
strength today he was desperate to find
anything to brag about so he reached
back to touting obamacare
but all i could hear was angry quacking
the only
reason the insurance company has to
cover it it's because of that law i
promise you i'm going to keep fighting
for you are you prepared to fight with
me i don't want to hear any more of
these lies
about reckless spending
we're changing people's lives
okay he's scaring me now people's lives
are changing all right the average
american family is now having to spend
an average of 460 dollars more every
month because of these skyrocketing
costs for gas food and housing
everything else that's about five
thousand dollars a year
now now i realize that 500k a year is
nothing for the biden family where
they're raking in hundreds of thousands
of dollars for hunters spitting on a
piece of paper
but to regular people working people
that added cost is a killer
it could mean rating your retirement
savings or going into debt
so the ruin that biden's causing the
domestic front it's gut wrenching but
tonight we're going to talk about the
warnings the flashing red warnings for
our national security as well
china is on the move tonight
with democrat leaders young and old
signaling the biden's one and done china
knows that they have a two and a half
year window to solidify its path to push
us out of asia and then of course
nail down their strategic alliances
around the world in just the past few
weeks
we've seen just how determined they are
to achieve global domination
now we have new satellite images of
their third and most advanced aircraft
carrier that gives china critical new
naval reach
it's showing biden who's boss they're
also buzzing their planes closer and
closer to taiwan every day
and now they're threatening war against
anyone who tries to defend taiwan's
independence
and then just a few hours ago taiwan
told reuters that war in taiwan would
hit the global economy harder than the
global economy has been hit with russia
and ukraine and the angle agrees with
that assessment
biden is so clueless
he probably thinks i don't know computer
chips that are made in taiwan are as
easy to make
i don't know potato chips it's easy just
pump them out
then to top it all off as biden's party
is busy dragging its previous president
through the mud
well the ccp is propelling its nuclear
arsenal into rapid expansion which they
described to be occurring at a moderate
and appropriate level
so how does biden's defense secretary
answer that
well by going out of his way to reassure
china
we do not seek confrontation or conflict
and we do not seek a new cold war
an asian nato
or a region split into hostile blocks
we're working closely with both our
competitors and our friends
to strengthen the guard rails against
conflict
and that includes fully open lines of
communication
with china's defense leaders
oh my
god environment is banned of bumblers
they're not just reassuring china as
austin just did they're rewarding china
because any minute now president xi is
going to learn that all of his sable
saber rattling all of his economic
sabotage and of course the coveted lies
in the cover-up that all paid off
because america's lame duck is about to
lift trump's tariffs
further strengthening china's hand and
sucker-punching u.s manufacturing
so the biden people are just frantic to
lower tariffs on china even though they
know it won't do any good this isn't the
new york times tonight an influential
study this year predicted that a move to
lift tariffs could save households 797 a
year but administration officials say
the actual effect would most likely be
far smaller and then there's more from
the times
any move to tweak the tariffs could
carry significant trade-offs it could
encourage companies to keep their supply
chains in china undercutting another
white house priority to bring jobs back
to america
well
sleazy pro-china lobbyists they don't
care about jobs in the united states and
the chamber of commerce they're doing
backflips tonight
so is this the product of a compromised
biden family vis-a-vis china do the
elites in washington already think that
the united states has lost the global
race with china
so in other words why not help clear the
field for an easier transition
well these are all disturbing questions
but
we should ponder them think about them
seriously think about them
what we do know though is that our lame
duck president is sounding more like a
bad actor in a film that went straight
to video
the bottom line is this
i truly believe we've made extraordinary
progress by laying a new foundation for
our economy you know trump did not leave
a very good
situation you think i'm kidding i say
america's back and they look at me and
they say
for how long
no one
literally
no one thinks that biden will do
anything except embarrass us on the
world stage
the white house announced an upcoming
trip to saudi arabia in july maybe
you've heard about that undoubtedly
they're just going to beg for
saudi arabia not u.s manufacturing but
beg for saudi arabia to produce more oil
now even the friendly press seems pretty
embarrassed
would he be holding official talks with
mbs if gas was not at five dollars a
gallon the president will and he said
this before he will meet with leaders
across the world if it's in the best
interest of the american people if it's
our national security interest and he
believes this trip in its entirety all
the discussions he's going to be having
over the course of those three days
absolutely fit that bill
oh my god how does he wake up in the
morning now biden hobbled america he
sabotaged us he sapped us of our energy
independence then when he goes hat in
hand to the most despotic regimes on
earth for help
the man wants a standing ovation from us
sorry joe
you're being booed off the stage and you
don't even know it
unfortunately for us we have two and a
half more years of a clown show to
endure
it's going to be up to a new republican
congress to begin to defund the woke
madness at the pentagon
shut down the money spigot and prepare
for a new president who believes in
america first once again and that's the
angle hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else